well after weeks of controversy now the
Las Vegas City Council has a new mayor
pro-tem that position fills in for the
mayor if needed
councilman Stavros Anthony has now
replaced Michele Fiori she is accused of
making racially charged comments and did
stepped down last month Hector McKee has
been following those for us he is live
outside City Hall with the details hi
Hector
hey there in every Las Vegas City
Councilmember including Michelle fury
herself voted to elect Stavros Anthony
as mayor pro-tem he was asked by Mayor
Carolyn Goodman to resume that position
which is a role he is familiar with I
think she selected me because we had a
good working relationship those first
four years and she has faith in my
common sense and you know my 29 years
with the Las Vegas much pomp Police
Department
councilman Stavros Anthony was mayor
pro-tem from 2011 to 2015 during mayor
Goodman's first term he's replacing
Michele Fiori who stepped down after
only a year as mayor pro-tem she's
facing criticism for making remarks that
some people called racist comments at a
Clark County Republican convention last
month and moments before this morning's
vote Goodman thanked Fiore for her
service over the last year and I know
you've done it loyally with hard work
have been so reliable for us and I
appreciate that because of all the
issues with which we're dealing around
our state people feel like they need
more answers so since you guys are up
there and money does go towards you guys
being in those positions we know that we
just want you to know that you have an
invitation to have these conversations
because there's two sides to every story
fury will stay in her seat as
Councilwoman representing Ward six that
Ward covers the northwest part of the
valley and the county's Republican Party
called the Commons she allegedly made
last month as quote irresponsible
insensitive and inaccurate reporting
outside Las Vegas City Hall Hector Mejia
8 news now